the story behind the popular Clarks
botanical skincare line is one of
resilience and survival entrepreneur
Francesco Clark started the beauty line
as a kitchen sink operation but now it's
used by stars like Madonna Meryl Streep
and there's Julianne Moore six years
before he created the celebrated brand
Clark survived a devastating accident it
changed the course of his life forever
30 seconds before I was very proud and I
felt accomplished 30 seconds after I
felt like the biggest failure in the
world at only 24 years old Francesco
Clark's life changed in an instant it
was a beautiful day on Memorial Day
weekend I had a timeshare in Long Island
and there was a pool and I dove into
what I thought was the deep end with the
metal ring ladder that normally is in
the deep end was in the shallow end and
the second that I drove in my chin hit
the bottom of the pool and my head
snapped back with such force that it
shattered my c3 c4 vertebrae so I was
underwater with my arms out to the side
floating facedown unable to move unable
to move and alone and somebody walked
into the house luckily lifted my head
above the water and i said call 9-1-1
you just saved my life
his parents rushed to the hospital when
they received the horrific news so you
wake up from surgery and your parents
are there so the surgeon turned to my my
father and my mom and he said he will
never breathe on his own he'll never
speak
he'll never move his arms and forget
about his legs for the rest of his body
and while my dad is looking at it my mom
turns to me and an Italian she says
spall staccato causa move something in
English and I looked at her and I was
like well if my mom says I have to move
something I have to move something so I
touched my shoulder and she looked back
at the surgeon and she said you don't
know our son what is your dad's reaction
to another doctor saying that about you
when the surgeon said he will never move
her breathe or I mean he was defining my
life is non-human
talking about me as if I was not there
and my father turns to him and said I I
really hope you do not speak to other
patients in this way and the searches
just looked at him and my dad said I'm a
medical doctor as well and this is in no
way the way that we were taught to speak
to people Francesco's injury left him
paralyzed from the neck down with years
of physical therapy his progress would
defy odds but four years after the
accident he struggled with depression
tell us about your recovery everyday
adapting to what it means to have a new
life redefining herself so I could not
look in a mirror for being be in a room
with a lot of windows because all I
would notice was wheelchair you didn't
want to see yourself in a chair I could
not because all I would notice was these
four wheels that I sat on and not the
person that was in it and I would burst
into tears every time that I saw it at
what point did you say I've got to do
something this has got to change the day
that everything changed for me was
hearing Barbara Walters
announced on TV that Christopher Reeve
passed away he was the biggest advocate
for people with spinal cord injuries and
so the day that he passed I realized
that my Superman had disappeared and
then I also realized that I had not done
enough to take responsibility for what
happened in my life so when you finally
looked at yourself in the mirror you
thought I got to do what I did not look
like myself my skin looked like it was
10 years older than it was it was very
dry anything and everything that could
go wrong with your skin went wrong with
my skin because it stopped sweating
because of my injury with help from his
father a medical doctor also trained in
homeopathy Francesco would create his
own skin care blend at home and when
they started to notice that my skin
started to look good my sister said well
if it looks good on Francesco I'm just
gonna steal a couple of these vials and
just use them and then my mom started to
say you know I'm gonna steal a couple of
vials as well so I created this triangle
of kleptomaniacs
of these products that we were making in
the kitchen but it was just something
that I was doing for myself humble
beginnings for what would become
skincare brand Clarke's botanicals it's
more than a company it represents a
renewed sense of purpose for Francesco
so after Clarke's botanical started I
emailed the CEO of the Christopher Reeve
Foundation and then I met with every
director I was just meeting with them
because I wanted to do more and to be
involved and I felt like it was a very
grassroots way of me giving back to
something that gave me a reason for
living about five weeks they called me
and they asked me to become one of their
national ambassadors and a lot to you it
meant the world to me one of your
mantras is vanity saved my life I like
the juxtaposition of the phrase vanity
saved my life because it catches you
off-guard
and it makes you think that's such a
stupid thing to say
with beauty there's a sense of
vulnerability it means a lot to me to
connect to other people on that in that
way I am so smitten with him Norah you
know we did something on him in the
magazine that's how I met him and then I
met him in person at the magazine and
was listening to his story said this is
a good story can I tell this story but
the thing about him is that he is so
determined and so resilient and I think
outside of the fashion industry you
might not have heard of Clarke's
botanicals but a lot of people have
heard of it that's why my skin looks so
radiant today John as you were
commenting yes right and so the company
is now a ten million dollar business and
he has already defied the odds he does
believe that he will work again
he will walk again rather he's already
moving arms and legs that they said
would never happen and he believes that
somewhere in the future that he will
walk again and I believe him too plus
you see he's got personality plus he's
now 40 years old he has love in his life
he has a supportive family
he's an amazing amazing it's a universal
story a lesson that can be learned from
that as many people feel that her life
is over yes and it's not and that's
destroyed a story of resilience and
falling huge and have someone believe in
you like his mom as parents he said
there's products he said it very calming
but he's a ng users probably his mom
said move something yeah and when he
said that that was a trigger for him how
dared the doctor those safe by now that
not knowing that his own dad was a
metaphor his father for silly cats a
great gun yeah I was texting my friends
how you got a secret I see a movie
potential hider too